قال اطباء بريطانيون ان طفله مصابه بسرطان
الدم اللمفاوي الحاد تعافت بعد اخداعها
لعلاج جديد يستخدم الخلايا المناعيه
المعدله وراثيا اجريت التجربه سريريه في
مستشفى
الاطفال في لندن وقال الفريق الطبي انها
تفتح افاقا واعده لعلاج ذلك النوع الفتاك
من سرطان الدم المنتشر بين الاطفال
وامراض السرطان والمناعه في جامعه
يعني اهميه هذا الانجاز العلميه اليوم
نتحدث عنه وليس فقط بالنسبه لهذا النوع من
السرطان ولكن اللي بحوث السرطان عموما
مساء الخير للمشاهدين اكيد من اهم
الاكتشافات التي صارت في
دواء لمرض السرطان هي
الدواء اللي بيستعمل العلاج المناعي واللي
باكد هذا الحكي انه بالالف 2018 نوبل فايت
في المدرسه
بتعمل سرطان الدم محلات معينه وكمان في
استجابه كانت كثير منيحه انا ما بحاله
البنت اللي صمت اليسا بهذه الحاله السرطان
ما بيستجيب ابدا لاي عائله بعد الطريقه
التقنيه اللي استعملوها اخذوا اخذوا
خليه عمانيه من شخص هاوس ما عنده بصحه
جيده
يعني عملوها هندسوه بطريقه انه تروح وتفتك
بسرطان الدم اللي عند هذه الفتاه وهذا
وهذا وهذه الهندسه الذكيه اللي بنقول عنه
هي اللي قدرت تقضي على الخلايا السرطانيه
الموجوده عند هذه الفتاه لانه بنعرف نحنا
اذا بدنا نعمل
شوكي ما بنقدر نعمله الا لما يكون المريض
ما بيكون في اي دليل انه في حاله سرطان
بقى بهذه التقنيه اضع على هذا السرطان عند
البنت قدرت تعمل يعني خاشقجي ثاني مره
وهلا بحاله جيد يعني
فعاله في نوع فتاك كهذا النوع من السرطان
هل هذا يعطي امل لانواع اخرى اقل شراسه
لنقل
ميه بالميه ميه بالميه لانه الشغله
الوحيده الي لازم نعرفها لازم نعرف اي
جيني او اي بروتين موجود على سطح خلايا
السرطان عند المريض فنقدر نهندس خلايا
المنيعه ضد هذا السرطان هذه الشغله
الوحيده اللي بنفتقدها بس هلا مع هذه
الحاله وحالات كثير
بكميه كثير كبيره
مستعمله على انواع سرطان كتير مثل ما
حضرتك قلتي واكيد راح يكون نتيجه كثير
احسن بقى كثير بعد هذه النتيجه
الان هل تواجه اي صعوبات خاصه ان همم
تحدثنا عن منطقه العربيه مثلا
اكيد بالمشكله بكثير لانه العلاج تكلفته
كثير عاليه
ياللي تستعمل يعني عنا بده يكون في
مختبرات مخصصه
اكيد هذا مش معناتها انه نحن العالم
العربي ما راح نقدر نعمل او نستعمل هذه
التقنيه بس لازم يكون انا يمكن الدول دول
محليات مخصصه للعلاج المناعه لانه هذا راح
يكون شيء كثير اكيد يستعمل للمرحله الجايه
مع ان شاء الله يكون فيه اذا مستشفيات او
في دول تقدر تاخذ هذا الرساله بعين
الاعتبار وتقدر تطبقه شكرا جزيلا لك
امراض السرطان والمناعه في جامعه حدثنا من
بوسط وهي جرعه امل جديد شكرا جزيلا لك